OK, so today we're jumping into
something pretty fascinating.
It's this question of, well, who
really shapes culture?
For the longest time, right, we
were kind of told it was, you
know, the academics and their
ivory towers, maybe powerful
financiers or even that sort of
whispered idea of a gay agenda.
Yeah, like some kind of secret
script being passed around.
Exactly.
But the sources we've been
digging into, they suggest
something completely different.
They basically say if you wanted
to find the real authors, the
ones holding the cultural pen.
You didn't need to look in
boardrooms or faculty lounges.
Nope, you just needed to hang
out near a high school
auditorium late on a Thursday
night.
It really does shift the focus,
doesn't it?
All that energy spent looking
for these like grand
manipulators when the material
we looked at points backstage to
this, well, surprisingly
powerful source of influence
that was hiding in plain sight.
Right there amidst the, you
know, the dodgy sound effects
and the smoke machine that never
quite worked properly.
That's where you find them, what
our sources can affectionately
call the Flitty Floofs.
Flitty Floofs.
Yeah, it's a memorable term.
It is, and this deep dive is
really all about figuring out
how these tacticians of the
stage, as the sources put it,
use their kind of good script to
basically change how we think
about things like sexy or safe,
even what it means to be
masculine today.
And that leads us to exploring
these newer archetypes, right?
Like the Zaddy and the the Bud
Light dad.
Exactly.
And how the stage in a way, has
become this new battleground for
identity.
So let's start there with this
group.
The sources point to the theater
kids.
We were so busy looking
elsewhere, right?
Academics, financiers, that
whole phantom script idea, the.
Tweety tenured wonks or the deep
cabal?
Yeah.
That the sources say Nope.
The real action was backstage.
Precisely.
And they were there way before
we even started talking about
cultural wars.
The research paints this
picture.
You know, sitting cross legged
on some worn out carpet,
swapping back massages, wearing
first store finds that smelled
faintly of mothballs and maybe
some late night tears.
Oh.
Yeah, I can picture it and.
They'd audition for the part of
a tree you know and commit so
hard you'd think they were
actually photosynthesizing.
Totally.
They'd weep openly, hold each
other's faces, sing pop songs
like their life depended on it.
And in a way, maybe it did.
Which brings us to that key idea
from the sources, them being
tacticians of the stage.
That's such a great phrase.
It really captures how they
operated.
Understanding that, you know a
good story, a good script, is
way more powerful than a sharp
sword when it comes to shaping
the world.
Exactly.
They understood narrative
emotion.
They always kind of held the
script, subtly influencing our
dreams, the things we whisper to
ourselves.
So when we say they held the
script, what does that actually
mean in practice?
Well, it means they weren't just
acting out parts, they were sort
of intuitively mapping human
emotion, social dynamics.
And this ties into that core
archetype, the Flitty Floof.
OK, let's unpack right?
So the sources are clear.
It's affectionate, it's self
adopted, never used as a slur.
It describes that fae
flamboyant, emotionally porous
performer.
So it's more than just a person,
it's like an attitude.
Exactly.
An identity, an attitude, a mix
of theatricality, maybe a
certain touchiness, but also
this real openness, this
willingness for self revelation.
You can really see that in those
early descriptions, the original
fliddy floofs, they were kind of
teaching us how to hold space
before that was even a phrase,
right?
Absolutely.
They just crack open emotionally
right there, maybe in the
cafeteria, and let you see your
own fragile bits reflected
without any judgment.
And the sources even mention a
specific subgroup, the tree
people.
Yeah, the tree people, those
were the kids who even if they
were playing a rock or, you
know, the wind, they pour so
much emotional depth into it.
They held the vibe together.
As the sources say, they're sort
of the ancestors of every modern
flitty floof who keeps the
energy right at a party.
So is that deep emotional
availability, the theatricality,
the courage to be vulnerable,
that's the source of their
influence?
That's what the research
suggests.
That's what makes the Flitty
Floof this powerful, even if
often unseen, cultural engine.
OK, so here's where it gets
really interesting, I think.
How does this fliddy floof
legacy connect to how our idea
of sexy has changed over time?
Right The sources propose that
what they call the queer male
imagination, or more directly,
the male gaze, has had this
really subtle but profound
effect on what we find sexy in
men and women and they.
Use Sex in the City as an
example.
They do.
It's called a touchstone, right?
Famously a show with huge appeal
within the gay community.
The idea presented is that
Carrie and her friends, while
aspirational for many women,
really embodied a certain
sensibility.
How so?
Well, the humor, the banter, the
whole aesthetic.
The research suggests it
resonated deeply with that male
gaze perspective that these
women were, in a sense, acting
out these flamboyant flitty
spoof versions of the modern
libertine.
So it's not like a conspiracy,
but more like.
More like a poetic
inevitability, as the sources
frame it.
When the people who understand
performance and narrative so
well end up writing the lines,
those lines tend to catch on.
And this isn't new.
This goes back decades, the 60s,
seventies, the Peacock men.
Exactly.
Think Mick Jagger, those hips
like switchblades or David Bowie
constantly playing with gender.
And Prince, he called him, the
Flitty Floof of all time.
In purple.
Yeah, Terrifyingly beautiful.
More than man enough.
The key insight there is how
these figures use theatricality
fluidity.
They made vulnerability and
flamboyance part of masculine
sex appeal.
Then the 80s hit hair bands.
Oh yeah, the hair band.
Flitty floofs, Poison Mötley
Crüe, mascara, smudged spandex,
lace, what the material calls
reckless peacockry.
It wasn't subtle.
Not at all.
It was wild, messy, and it
really cemented the flitty floof
as a permanent resident of the
American libido.
That performative gender bending
masculinity became a rock'n'roll
standard for sexy.
But then the pendulum swung hard
in the 90s.
Heroin shake.
Totally different 5 suddenly
desire was about absence
vulnerability.
Kurt Cobain in that moth eaten
cardigan you.
Call him a flitty floof in ruin.
Exactly beautiful because he was
breakable, visible bones, eyes
like bruises.
It was the anti boulder look.
Sexiness shifted from showing
off to this fragile, maybe
wounded, authenticity.
Revealing something deeper, more
emotional.
Right.
And then came the 2000s and the
metrosexual.
Ah yes, the watered down flitty
floof for the suburbs.
Kind of the straight guy, using
hair product, plucking eyebrows,
carrying a man bag.
It felt like a costume for a
while, but it stuck it.
Did and the material highlights
this as the moment a guy could
borrow that flitty floof
wardrobe shine without, you
know, giving up his dad hood
card.
It really shows how that
aesthetic influenced by the
queer male imagination just
seeped into the mainstream,
didn't it?
Blurring those old lines.
Absolutely.
Which brings us pretty much up
to today and this whole new
script playing out this contrast
between the Zaddy and the Bud
Light dad.
OK.
But before the Zaddy, we have to
acknowledge the other side, what
the source is called the boulder
shoulder holder.
Right.
That super hyper jacked, like 3%
body fat look.
The superhero aesthetic, your
Hemsworths, your Jackman's.
Yeah.
Action Hero standard.
But here's the irony.
The sources point out that
physique, which is now peak
mainstream action?
Masculinity.
It actually got its start in the
gay underground.
No way.
Really.
Yeah.
Think old school Muscle
magazines.
It's another example of how that
queer male imagination
influenced the broader culture
in ways people might not even
realize.
What was niche became the norm
for heroic men on screen?
OK, so contrasting that is the
soft zaddy.
This hybrid creature, yeah, born
in the queer corners of slang,
the definition being like
protective kind of bear leaning,
but also slutty daddy.
It's a specific combo.
Very specific and the analysis
really points to Pedro Pascal's
the prime example right now, the
reigning flitty floof Zaddy.
What makes him fit the mold so
well?
It's his ability to slide
between and being that gruff
protector, the father figure,
and then suddenly dropping this
sly, charming, almost flirty
vibe, that slutty daddy aspect.
He.
Seeks gay bar banter but with
stoicism.
That's a quote from the sources,
right?
Exactly.
It's a carefully calibrated
performance, a script that
really hits that Zaddy archetype
perfectly.
And you have others may be
trying to fit that mold, like
Stephen Colbert.
Well, the sources discuss his
transformation from the sharp
tongued mask wearer of his old
show to this more flitty floof
in dad glasses persona now
dancing, giggling, the safe late
night gesture.
But the sources bring up that
Mean Girls line stop trying to
make fetch happen.
You can't just force a vibe, it
has to feel authentic.
Right, you can't just put on the
costume.
Exactly.
The authentic flitty floof just
is.
Which leads us to the
counterpoint, the Bud Light dad.
The old, stoic, untouchable
American man.
Yeah.
Often seen as like, emotionally
underfed but fiercely loyal in
his own quiet way.
His strength isn't in speeches,
it's in actions, in silence.
He's a reminder that maybe
masculinity didn't need a total
rewrite.
Just yes, room to breathe.
That's a core argument in the
material he represents a kind of
masculinity that exists without
needing the performative layer.
OK.
But this raises a really
important kind of critical
point.
What happens when this flitty
flu way of being, which started
as maybe offering permission,
starts feeling compulsory?
Yeah, the sources warned about
this, about a new kind of closet
being built.
How so?
Well, the original flitty floof,
The research is really clear on
this.
They never asked anyone else to
become them.
They just wanted space to be
them.
They offered permission.
Right, permission to be
vulnerable, authentic.
But the danger now, according to
the analysis, is that this
ritual of permission is getting,
well, flattened, turned into APR
strategy.
So the very people who
championed being real are
accidentally creating a new box.
That's the irony, highlighted
the theater.
Kids might own the pen now, but
their authentic movement risks
being Co opted turn into a new
set of expectations everyone has
to meet.
Which leads to what the sources
call this inherent absurdity.
Yeah, this idea that every stoic
man has to be a zaddy now, or
every dad has to be slutty daddy
adjacent.
Or that say an ex military guy,
the bed like dad type must learn
the language of the flitty floof
to be considered OK, safe,
enlightened, desirable.
The sources basically scream no,
that's absurd, it's not true.
It takes something genuine and
turns it into a performance
requirement.
It misses the whole point of
authenticity versus just acting
apart.
Completely.
The original spirit was about
opening up, not about telling
everyone else how they have to
be.
Once it becomes mandatory, it's
not liberating anymore.
So where does that leave us
navigating all this?
Well, the sources come back to
that metaphor.
The world is a stage, but a good
stage needs room for every kind
of player.
Not just one type.
Exactly.
There has to be room for the
tree people, the flitty floofs
crying under the spotlight.
There's room for the zaddies,
the slutty daddies, the Fay boys
and eyeliner, the glam boys and
lace.
But also, crucially, as the
research really hammers home,
there must be room for the Bud
Light dad, the one who has no
mask to drop, no big speech,
whose love is just a quiet
presence that outlasts applause.
He gets a place at the cast
party, too, even if he doesn't
dance like Colbert or flirt like
Pascal.
He has to.
That's the point.
And the core message from all
this seems to be improvisation.
Freedom to improvise your lines.
That's it.
The only thing worse than the
old closets, the sources argue,
is building a new one out of
rainbow curtains and someone
else's glitter script.
Just letting people be who they
are, yeah.
That freedom is paramount.
OK, so let's wrap this up.
We've taken this deep dive into
how maybe surprisingly, it was
the theater kids, the flitty
floofs who've been holding the
pen on culture.
Not some secret group, but these
vulnerable performative souls
shaping how we see sexy from,
you know, Mick Jagger swagger to
today's zaddies shifting the
script through performance, not
force.
And the material definitely
suggests that, yes, the theater
kids are at the table now.
They hold the pen.
But the final thought from the
sources is for you, the
listener.
You still hold your own tone.
May you?
Find your lines.
May you improvise your lines.
And maybe most importantly, may
you never let someone else's
fetch become your closet.
The stage is waiting, whether
you flip or floof or just stand
strong in your own quiet way.